sehr geehrte damen und herren nach
monaten der vorbereitung und der
beschlussfassung im sonderministerrat am
nationalfeiertag freue ich mich ihnen
gerade jetzt in einer sehr turbulenten
zeit in einer schwierigen zeit ein so
wichtiges programm für österreich
nämlich das programm
mein dienst für österreich vorstellen zu
dürfen mit diesem programm verfolgen wir
zwei ziele wir wollen zum einen den
grundwehrdienst attraktiver machen und
wir wollen die miliz stärken
denn gerade die korona krise oder auch
die schrecklichen ereignisse des
terroranschlages haben uns gezeigt wie
wichtig sicherheit ist wie wichtig
insbesondere das österreichische
bundesheer und die miliz ist und das
schaffen wir so zum ersten werden wir
den fokus auf die ausbildung legen
künftig wird der grundwehrdienst
insbesondere der militärischen
ausbildung gewidmet sein und es werden
auch zusatzausbildungen im
grundwehrdienst absolviert sein
wir bitten als bundesheer eine vielzahl
von weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten an
das beginnt bei der sanitätsausbildung
geht über hygiene ausbildungen bis hin
zum lkw schein oder auch zum programm
ihr kurs das alles das alles das soll
künftig für grundwerte ihnen nutzbar
sein
zweitens es soll auch mehr geld für die
grundwehrdiener geben wenn sich junge
männer zur miliz melden also zu 30
übungstagen verteilt auf zehn jahre zu
erhalten sie ab dem dritten monat um 400
euro monatlich zusätzlich zu ihrem soll
ja und das dritte ist ein spezieller
finanzieller anhalts zusätzlich noch für
die miliz kaderausbildung hat sich der
wehrpflichtige erst zur miliz gemeldet
man kann auch schon den ersten teil der
kommandanten ausbildung absolvieren und
erhält sie monatlich weitere 200 euro
vierter punkt die assistenzeinsätze nach
dem grundwehrdienst ich weiß und wir
wissen dass viele junge männer die zeit
zwischen dem grundwehrdienst oder dem
beruf staat beziehungsweise im studium
überbrücken wollen oder müssen bei uns
beim österreichischen bundesheer da
können sie diese zeit sinnvoll nutzen
ab jetzt können die grund wird ihnen
einen dreimonatigen assistenzeinsatz
direkt nach dem grundwehrdienst
absolvieren
dabei erhalten sie ein sehr großes
finanzielles plus
sie sehen es gibt unglaublich viele neue
chancen die wir bieten werden
ich lade sie alle einig lade alle jungen
männer daher ein nutzen sie die chance
leisten sie ihren dienst für österreich